so did you watch the fight in its
entirety did either of you I hung out
with the dude who is a fighter like a
boxing guy yeah boxing coach and uh he
was talking about the guy who has the
loose jaw and saying like he should stop
fighting because he like gets he gets
hit in the jaw every time and then he's
out uh uh that makes sense
weird answer did you watch the fight
yeah no but I was I was hanging out with
a boxer one time
I was also trying to show that I have
friends outside of Hawaii
I definitely believe you yeah we believe
that that friend is real I got cornered
into taking shrooms hardcore like
cornered by the guy same guy no hey yeah
wait what do you mean cornered like
someone's like it was chocolates uh
chocolate shrooms and he had it in his
pocket and everyone else was taken and I
was like no I'm good it was like 11
o'clock at night oh [ __ ] I was like yeah
I was like ready to go home and uh
they're all like eating shrooms and I
was like
um I think I'm gonna Uber soon and then
they were like no dude just take one I'm
like no I'm okay like I think I'm just
gonna like uber soon and then they're
like dude just try it just have one and
I kept saying no and they're just
they're you know back forth and then I
ate it and then I had another one after
yeah did you trip uh I had a body hat I
had I had some uh dark like feeling at
two o'clock in the morning and I was
brushing my teeth and I was afraid to
look at myself in the mirror so I was
just like staring straight down and I
like put the toothbrush back in and I
like closed the or turned off the light
and I like walked backwards out of the
bathroom just so I didn't look at the
mirror that's the mushroom thing it was
like yeah it was bad my first song was
with Walid and his cousin who's a
Satanist oh yeah oh yeah
I have a cousin who I guess got pushed
religion on super hard and it just came
out totally opposite
piercings as a tattoo that says served
no master on his chest it's sick except
for Satan
and he came over one time to do shrooms
and Zach was down and Zach didn't have a
good time I did not know us we literally
did the complete opposite of how you're
supposed to do shirts like we were
sitting in the living room like we
didn't go outside at all we were just
watching Disney like shorts Pixar shorts
and we were just like I didn't feel it
at first so then I went and got more
they [ __ ] with me the whole time
they're like dude this is never gonna
end man like you're the way you're
thinking right now it's never gonna
Never Gonna it's not like the real-life
version of the nightmare nightmare yeah
yeah yeah that's what they did to it
yeah but you did it also to himself
because he would ask those questions
like you guys ever think about how
there's like Society just has these laws
and my cousin's like yeah
and then I was like do you guys feel
like a god right now like I feel like
we're all three gods and they're just
like yeah dude like they were like
totally fine I was like so Zach you're
being [ __ ] weird it's just shrooms
yeah dude I remember at one point Zach
went into his bedroom it was girl dubs I
wanted yeah but I wanted to stab myself
to end the whole like because they know
they said it's never gonna end so I was
like I want to [ __ ] go now this is it
so while he well he came in my room and
was just like dude we're just [ __ ]
with you man like and it was just like
trying to cook but seriously it's never
gonna
I hated it and I also hate it the second
time but we're doing it a third time in
Denver we are bachelor party bachelor
party
yeah you guys can come yeah I missed the
invite you guys ever do uh anything
jug-related you guys do Ayahuasca no
never done that Aaron Rodgers
quarterback for the Packers yeah they
just did Ayahuasca and he like posted
about it yeah he's outward he's outward
about he's out he's out
so did he talk about like the ceremony
and then like having to do the [ __ ]
afterwards where you the integration
it's called it's like a multi-step thing
it's like you have to prepare for it by
like eating certain things how far did
you get in the process my friend did it
so he
I got he told me like all about it my
friend and his brother did it and yeah
it's like you have to
they tell you what to eat and all this
stuff for like a week leading up you
can't drink you can't you have to make
sure to get good sleep and all this
stuff and then you go to the place they
guide you through the whole thing a lot
of the times when you take it you throw
up right afterwards because it's just
like a card on your body or whatever
kind of like I mean shrooms are pretty
gross right it's just super nasty makes
you feel sick to your stomach so you
puke and then you come up like crazy
trip for a while and then I guess a lot
of times guys will like or and girls or
whoever will go and do these things and
have crazy epiphanies and then change
their lives the next day that's so
they've learned now to do like
integration meetings for the next like
for the following three or four weeks
after the ceremony you have to meet with
someone else in the group and basically
just like talk about what you learned so
that you don't make drastic changes to
your life because God you know they've
they've had people that like go in as an
investment banker and the next day
they're like I I don't I can't work in
finance anymore it's soul sucking I've
been doing the wrong thing my whole life
and I'll quit amen maybe I took Iowa
yeah maybe you didn't even know the
firing was like the best thing that ever
happened to me yeah I wish I could have
some money but you know other than that
are you happier now like do you feel
like I feel less stressed yeah really
yeah I mean I just played Pokemon go I
don't know well he gave me his Game Boy
and I just been playing it not Pokemon
go it's probably the stupidest [ __ ]
thing I've ever said
the UN coolest thing I've ever said not
Pokemon go there are plenty of people
who [ __ ] with that yeah and that was the
yellow Pikachu Game Boy Advance oh dude
just play that on stream okay cool there
you go run it yo are you the Duke of
mine that's you get on Twitch like are
you the guy from Vine you're like yeah
then they're like you're a speed Runner
now that's sick do you guys do you guys
still get that when you people stop you
on the streets like are you the guy from
Vine yeah I said that when Brian was on
that was like the one time it's happened
in Forever some girl was like oh my God
oh my God you're the [ __ ] guy I used
to watch you on Vine and I was like you
should check out the other stuff I've
been doing she's like nah yeah
it's been like eight years when they ask
you like are you still like doing stuff
I'm like yeah I [ __ ] post like every
single day yeah I don't care dude I'm
not on social media anymore you get
recognized as Market guy yeah as the
market guy Market guy or either because
I used to work at a company called all
deaf dudes from Long Beach like hey you
that stupid clown right yeah yeah
I guess that's me I will say that one
time that I did acid I don't think I've
ever said this story before it was like
what possibly the worst day of my life
we had planned on doing it on a Saturday
or something like that we went out
Friday night didn't get any sleep you
know was like super hungover woke up
went surfing came back so I was like
even more tired and then we were like
okay we're gonna drop and go to Malibu
so I was really nervous and tired and
hungover and so we're all like okay
let's go to Malibu let's do this
hour-long drive right now so we hop in
the back my friend's girlfriend was
driving and she drives like a [ __ ]
Fiat it was like a smart car oh yeah
tiny right so she's driving friends and
shotgun and then me and my buddy are in
the back we go and pick up her dog we
stop at her like family house to pick up
her dog I didn't know any of this was
gonna happen right I'm like severely
allergic to dogs and it's like a lassie
type dog so this [ __ ] dog jumps in
the back seat and is sitting in between
my buddy and I and it's just fur just
like everywhere and so I'm sitting there
like [ __ ] I'm allergic but okay and I
start just sneezing running nose right
and now I'm like starting to hit me it's
starting to come up
and we still have this hour-long drive
to Malibu she's a horrible driver so
we're like stopping going stopping it's
like PCH traffic the whole way and we go
to Zuma Beach that's where we like
wanted to end up and it's like gusting
winds yeah it must have been 30 knot
wins that day families [ __ ]
everywhere and people's like chairs are
like ripping out of the ground like you
know people's like run yeah [ __ ] it's
just like that and we're sitting there
and I'm like
is that a Vine joke no
he's family like I thought you were
talking about that vinyl I know exactly
what you're talking about no it's like
making a joke that all the families
wanted to get out and I'm like tripping
my balls off sitting on the beach
freezing my ass you're sorry
good it's okay dude it's okay it's okay
I tripped my ball off too we all trip
color's like my bed so it's tripping my
job off wait [ __ ] sorry sorry sorry
my bad I was tripping all the money
[Laughter]
and it was like so cold I'm sitting
there I'm just like [ __ ] tripping so
hard and I was wearing shorts I was
looking at my legs and all I could see
my leg hair was turning into like just
nasty like Vines and all I could think
was like this is never gonna end I knew
I was being weird because I like looked
over my friends and they were like yo
Cody's being [ __ ] weird
and I heard one of them say we gotta get
him out of there he's we got to get him
out of here he's freaking out oh God the
isolated event that was bad I what
you're like the isolated I was out of
that group I was like and that made it
worse because like I then saw my friends
freaking about me and I was like I don't
want to be the [ __ ] guy that ruins
the whole thing anywhere sorry my legs
are trees right now yeah and so they're
my buddy was like I know this guy owns
this Winery in Malibu I could text him
and I was like okay why I don't know he
would just like Snapchat with this guy
sometimes it was I don't know I I don't
[ __ ] know did he dealt with him yeah
we ended up driving to the top of this
you know where The Hangover 2 was filmed
it's on the purse on the top of a
mountain yeah and so we went there
and this guy had no idea that we were
all tripping on acid but it ended up
being the best
wow that's when like my trip like
finally turned and it was like oh [ __ ]
now I get it dude I was gonna say you
know the hangover too yeah
what I [ __ ] love that movie every
time I do shrooms I just have to [ __ ]
really bad wow all right interesting I
don't know if that's if anyone else gets
that or it's just me you did it in the
mountains did you I did I did [ __ ] in
the mountains oh that's [ __ ] crazy
and then I I like got my legs I don't go
that long I like my hike is like I don't
know like a couple miles and I'm back
like I don't have to [ __ ] that long
remember when I shot in the mountains I
popped the bottle on a hole so I could
use it as a bidet because I have a
potato we wanted to go so you put water
in and then just squeeze them squeeze
the bottle and it just sprayed up your
ass because it's kind of funny
it goes back into the camps I see oh
well we had the toilet paper right here
for you no it was nice because there was
a breeze too so my ass was not dry